hey guys welcome to meab bit Tomic Shay
how's it going I'm doing great I love
your intro thank you I didn't make it
but I love it too uh we're here today to
play uh Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
hyperstone Heist on the Sega Genesis but
more importantly more importantly we're
also here to show off the Retron console
from hyperkin uh they were kind enough
to send us a sample review unit and this
is their classic well it's a console
that emulates old systems using an
Android operating system on the inside
but it lets you use real cartridges
which is really nice and one of the
great things for us makes our life
easier is that it has HDMI out so this
beautiful upscaling it doesn't make
streaming hard at all it looks good so
it you could play Genesis Super Nintendo
NES game boy Game Boy Color Game Boy
Advance uh famicom there's a port for
that that because it has different
pinous than the NES really famicom is
the Japanese version of the Nintendo the
carts are smaller they have fewer pins
um and it's also got a lot of
interesting things like built-in uh Game
Genie support um lets you do save states
so you can save a game at any time and
go right back um yeah and you can do
things like run filters over games too
so in addition to them being upscaled
and looking really nice you can also
smooth out some of the pixelization so
that actually looks even better yes if
you will or in the case of Genesis games
good just
they do not normally look at such a
hater I know whatever I was a super I
was a Nintendo boy I was too but
actually when the Genesis came out
that's what I ended up having alth I
grew up with an neses um so I'll show
you some of the settings we have here
just to give you guys an idea oh it's
right behind our look we
could um there we go thanks guys uh so
these are a bunch of filters right here
I'll cycle through a few of them once
the game is running to give you an idea
of what they actually look like um you
can turn scan lines on if you want I'll
turn them off since we're doing this on
HD stream uh when I do like PS1 games on
the vaita I always make the aspat ratio
blown out I hate you which makes
everybody look kind of fat and chunky so
every game is a comedy but we're going
to play with the normal one because
you're you're a traditionalist well I
just don't traditional yeah yeah sure um
it's got a few audio enhancement things
although I don't really notice whole
much of that when I turn it on one of
the cool things too is that this comes
it comes with a wireless Bluetooth
controller but you can also use the old
controllers for the original systems but
more than that what you can do is use a
Genesis controller to play NES games or
an NES controller to play Super Nintendo
games and you can remap buttons and uh
make that a thing that's this seems like
a bad idea there's only two buttons on
the NES controller but you can do it but
you can do it so it doesn't matter like
I would probably just use the Super
Nintendo controller for everything that
would probably be where because I just
think that controller is is a good
controller you do love it I I think it's
pretty great um all right we're going to
jump in and I'm going to reset the game
yes so we're mostly for this hour going
to talk about what a hyperstone is and
what it is not and what it is not it is
not a normal Stone no it's
hyper it's a hyper Stone those are all
the facts we have yeah and I guess
they're heisting it right now well
they're in well either they're heisting
it or they're trying to prevent said
Heist
oh one way of looking at it so this is
the default uh filter which is just
straight pixels scaled the native aspect
ratio to you think Leonardo does
steroids I'm pretty sure they all do
steroids oh no not not only Leonardo
controversial I love the colors in this
game so is this what the game looked
like on the Genesis uh more or less you
ran at like 240p this is now upscaled to
run at either 720 or 1080 I'm not sure
what this TV is running um so it's
basically like an Xbox One game then
yeah it's exactly as as an Xbox cuz
those run into the sub sub resolution
damnn it Tom what this is a funny joke I
had to explain it that's true um all
right so do this thing uh I want to go
to the options real quick because it has
this really interesting option what did
he just say I've never heard of I I
don't
know color mode comic anime so what did
we do last time we did comic last time
we'll do anime This Time anime this time
so even though you guys can get to see
us do comic we're going to change it for
our own our own yeah we're whatever yeah
we're doing the Konami Code inside of
the game that's basically what we just
did I don't think we need to do a sound
test we're going to be hearing enough of
that think maybe we should no okay we're
g to hear enough of TMNT um so I'll show
you guys some of the filters on the
screen and then we'll land on one you
press down and start in any game it'll
open up this menu and let's see here I
we'll go for the wait do can you just do
for eag you knew what I was going to say
I didn't even have to finish it let's
see what super eagle looks like is that
by popular I don't know what it did but
it did something it did something what
did it do uh so it takes the pixels and
it sort of rounds them out based on
different algorithms and that's sort of
the way all these filters work just with
different algorithms I've never heard of
super eagal it sounds very
patriotic it's American
filter go with hq2x cuz high quality two
times yeah I noticed differences but I
couldn't tell you what the differences
are I know I
know uh point being though I think this
does kind of help bring the games a
little bit closer to what you'd expect
these days um although some of the art
can look really strange as in right here
these lines are really weird all right
I'm going to be donatell so why not did
you just say donatell you're Le Leonardo
I mean
sorry oh
no what was she reporting on the
hyperstone was she just doing a news
port in front of the Statue of Liberty
for no reason Manhattan are disappearing
and there's a bunch of people watching
that Statue of
Liberty that
is those
packs he's his veins are popping yeah
dude steroids man
jeez our high energy
detector apparently they didn't know
about hyphens back in the Genesis
days okay we're going go to New York
City ah we got to start in the
sewer I guess that makes sense their
home is probably like right right around
the corner right yeah the foot Clan's
like oh hey we're here now yeah so we
were talking about this earlier and I
think you were wrong
so are they robots I believe them to be
human cuz weren't weren't there uh video
games where like you cut off their limbs
and stuff and you see circuitry wasn't
that a thing in games I didn't I mean
okay maybe that was the thing I don't
remember it h do we have a chat open we
do cuz I don't I guess there's a
computer over there yeah but man we got
I know got foot to smash we should have
called Chris in here to just answer
questions about this he's not he's not
doing any work is he no he's totally not
busy at all on Mond day he's not busy
first thing in the morning
now and we got some really good sound in
the studio we got like the spir stereo
speakers going on it's
fun uh this game is very similar to uh
turtles and time uh the Super Nintendo
version of this game you could say uh
there are some slight differences to
some levels and um you can't do certain
things in this game like you can't throw
characters into the screen oh I was
trying to do that before ah but you
can't my friend is it because the
Genesis was kind of underpowered damn it
Tom they just couldn't handle it they
didn't have mode seven cuz that was all
mode seven they had uh blast processing
though which I don't well well that
wasn't a fake thing was it it was things
it was a fake thing cuz things did run
faster on the
Genesis like that was a thing wasn't it
well but the Genesis had like
co-processors compared to the single
processor on the Super Nintendo so
certain devs were able to do interesting
things with it uh including Konami and
that's who made this game and they're uh
legendary for having their own Studio or
own sorry their own teams for each
console so when you have these like
console games like you know this Turtles
game and sparkster and sunset Riders
between the Super Nintendo and Genesis
uh you would notice a lot of differences
because the games were made by different
teams especially in sparkster the games
are very very different from one another
I didn't know that that's pretty it
seems pretty smart doesn't it yeah I
mean back then they could afford to do
that right yeah when you didn't have
like 500 person teams right
basically can't really do do that
anymore um for anyone who doesn't
remember these Turtles games back in the
day I mean starting on the Nintendo well
I guess starting in the arcade but
really in the home it was the Nintendo
that began the Ninja Turtles video game
craze yeah the first one was that one
that was really hard really hard sides
scrolling and like top down like
exploration game top down exploration
and then you go underwater and try to
disarm bombs and it was impossible so
difficult oh hard Eric T is nodding
along with
that um and then after that they
released two other sides scrolling games
for the NES there was the Manhattan
Project and then ninja turtles the
Arcade was that the one that was all
about like uh the building of the of the
hbomb yes oh damn it was it Manhattan
Project hold on hold on I'm just going
to let you fight him I'm going to let
you win your own battle question and
fight real Fair H I don't remember the
plot but yeah oh no oh no who turned out
the
lights wait what does that graffiti say
wa wait this car us
jail it does say us jail this car is
going to do its thing there you
go we have that memorized from 30 years
ago not cuz we just played the game
yeah so how do I smoothly transition
from talking about this to Super Mario
Kart just cuz they came out the same
year is that awkward you just smoothly
transitioned this man I'm not really I'm
not really going to do that cuz then I'd
be compelled to talk about Mario Kart 8
and nobody wants to hear me talk about
the Mario the new Mario Kart just
because you're not allowed to yet I know
that's funny isn't it isn't it funny I'm
sure Nintendo wouldn't have a problem if
I said good things about it but I can't
say
anything oh darn it just said something
good about it though I didn't I didn't
say anything I didn't say anything I
didn't say anything you're fired
what um am I yeah you're you're kind of
fired so so so
oh we have a thing open up
here I don't know what people are saying
in the chat it's hard to follow chat and
play
TMNT I know I I'm not I'm not that
talented so is that ever weird to you
that like because Konami made all the
beat him UPS back in the day right I
guess Capcom did yeah Konami and Capcom
and other companies as well didn't did
Konami make all the licensed
ones no Capcom did Alien versus Predator
in the arcades uh they did some uh comic
book stuff did it ever seem weird that
that like these Japanese developers did
all these like pretty American licensed
games was that weird I don't think
that's weird I mean that's where the
talent for that sort of game was located
right so but do you think that they had
like a passion for The Simpsons they
probably had a passion for or just they
jobs or they just made it and did
whatever guess that's oh my God aliens
where's Ripley when you need her
this when we were talking about that I'm
always talking about Ripley oh no I I'm
I'm close to death do the thing where
you kill all the enemies and then give
me a
pizza I totally died Shell Shocked it's
cool they don't say Shell Shocked
anymore that's not uh politically
correct what no that's a it was a thing
when people come back from Vietnam they
were like shell shots oh yeah yeah yeah
okay fair enough uh that's not that's
not a thing we say anymore cuz it's
totally rude and insensitive the they
can get away with it cuz whatever
they're not they're not wearing any
pants and you can say anything victims
of nuclear
waste yeah kind of aren't
they victims or benefactors mutagen do
you think they're happier they're not
dude they I mean they've got to be
happier you are too immature to hang
with me always hating on teenagers what
I don't want to hang with you leather
face did you have all the toys growing
up or was that just me o all right so I
had a bunch but I had a really good
friend whose mother was a comic book
artist what but she also collected
action figures and I kid you not one
day my friend like brought me up to her
parents bedroom and like opened the
closet and I was like what's the big
deal she spread open a bunch of clothes
and there was a door behind the clothes
no took me do a secret attic filled with
every toy in in the action figure you
know Ninja Turtles action figure series
that was released in that point like
inbox hanging on the hanging on these
racks and we couldn't play with any of
them and I actually wasn't even supposed
to talk about just even knowing that
they were a thing you couldn't even what
yeah I know that's no fun I
know I mean I had my fair share I had
the [__] I had the van that that shot
pizza from the roof oh
yeah I had tons of these toys little
known facts crocodiles explode yeah well
not yeah but when I like we got rid of
them all when I moved in 98 which is
like get rid of them I didn't I didn't I
didn't want to get rid of all
them that's the thing that was gotten
rid of here we
go yeah I had I had I don't know
probably 100 or something of these of
them wow you have like like baseball
catcher Raphael I some of chef chef
Michaelangelo I love those D I remember
I had astronaut Raphael hell yeah um and
then there's or is it Michelangelo who's
an astronaut and then there's a Raphael
who was like wearing a mask and I had
that one also because he was detective
or something I don't know private eye
but I mean you know I just had you know
new toid man and Panda con and all these
like really dumb ones cuz why not
there's no dumb Turtles action figures
no I didn't actually have like the stuff
like the techn Drome and stuff I just
had the figures I didn't have the techn
Drome oh but I did have the uh the crang
figure oh was the big one no no it was
regular size you talking about like the
foot tall one yeah I didn't have that
one I didn't have that one that was
that's a little that's a little much
[__] that thing is weird CR CR is very
weird cuz why does why does he why does
his robot like look like a
man and then he puts himself at like the
crotch of the man so like like why why
is that a thing he could have done
anything he didn't have to do
that why not put it in the head I don't
know I think was weird whatever wi are
words I just you know as a kid this
would keep me up at night I just
couldn't understand it I had a friend
who want a contest to be in an episode
of the Ninja Turtles cartoon you had the
coolest is this a different friend
different friend I didn't know him until
I moved to San Francisco actually but he
told me the story is it van yes it's van
cooworker roommate van uh no it was uh
my buddy Zach and uh he won the contest
and then they eventually just put like
they had a cookie cutter like boy and
girl character it didn't matter what you
looked like so he was just this generic
kid named Zach they just dubbed his name
but they already had it like animated
but that's really cool it was kind of
cool but it wasn't like him necessarily
it was just his name so I don't know oh
that painting totally got me I would I
would be that would be like the first
thing on my
resume and like Okay Cupid account like
that would be the that would be the
first thing I played Zach in that one
episode of tmnc Tom you're married you
shouldn't have an okay keid
account
yeah I also have a job I shouldn't have
a resume these are just hypothetical
things also why is your resume on okay
keid well what do you mean that's where
I find all my best work yeah oh God this
not this is getting going to a weird
place well you
know all right I'm pretty sure we're
going to beat this game I really think
that you have the best weapon my SW it's
a sword it's swords actually but like so
I was comparing him to uh Leonardo to to
Cyclops earlier CU they're both Ultra
lame here's another here's another
comparison cuz you think let me compare
something else for you no because you
think you think that they you think that
Cyclops would have laser beams that
could like cut crap right but he doesn't
there a concussive laser beams and his
sword is the same kind of thing where it
doesn't cut anything it's like
concussive swords he's a teenager you
can't trust those guys with a real sword
he doesn't have neither of them sharp
objects they can't be trusted they're
going to hurt Claws and well the teeth
are kind of turtles have claws no they
don't turtles have claws dude no they
don't who was the last time you saw a
turtle well right now for one they don't
have massive claws but they claws they
short dude turtles have do we have claws
we as humans we the humans have claws I
guess and Nails we just trim them right
but we let those things grow out and we
use them as utilities I I don't think
claw humans would be a thing Turtles
can't even use their feet for anything
but like like standing
still the thing they can't they're not
using a claw attack on on enemies on
phas or praying on what do you think not
wol those [__] Got It Rock soldiers
they're from Dimension X they are it's
true everything good and bad in this
universe nope just everything bad
everything bad is from Dimension X ow my
toe I don't know if that'd be my
reaction
I like how they're wearing helmets they
they're there's no way their helmet is
as strong as rock they're Golems Golems
Golems Golems turtles have claws Justin
hawald thank you Justin hayal doesn't
know Justin hawald understand hawal lik
vaseline on
toast but he put cinnamon on it too it's
not just Vaseline oh God that's even
worse for some reason cinnamon Vaseline
toast so I have a lot more kills but I
also have died more I think no we've
haded the same amount but I have less
Health can I have the next Pizza yeah
you can eat the next Pizza okay you get
to it first yeah it's kind of how it
goes isn't
it most of these foot shoulders don't
even Attack One Time is what I've
noticed they're really bad at their
jobs what just fell from the ceiling on
us oh
Jesus
slag
tights close it's just a lack
a [__] with a c that's what I said it's
just my my accely it's my accent your
thick accent it's my thick because C is
thick uneducated accent C is for ceiling
and T for tights is is cuz it's grabbing
on from the ceiling that's how you can
know it and then the lag might G with on
the ground all right Professor no I
already died I already died this is how
you remember you're never going to
forget again now that I said ceiling
tight it's like a te it hangs from the
top yeah there you go
perfect Stites perfect perfect everybody
has one thing that they know and that's
the one thing that I
know Tom's exhausted his that's it
relative wealth of knowledge yeah I'm
pretty sure that they don't the turtles
don't have claws either I think I know
that dude Turtles are the most clawed
animal most clawed they have like eight
claws yeah no there's their claws are
the most clawed is of the of the CL
making stuff up I'm just who put purple
boots on these Rock men's
um uh I'm assuming Shredder it has to be
Shredder it's usually Shredder maybe it
was mayor Rudy Giuliani oh my God was he
mayor
92 Ro steady where's B oh my butt you
look delicious that's
disgusting they really love talking
about how they're going to eat the
turtles that was like their thing it's
all about soup
man you ever had turtle soup I bet it's
gross uh yeah I have actually that's
good
oh he is a real bad shot he shoots like
he's blind we're not doing so hot
ourselves I'm not too worried did you
get the pizza I got the
pizza oh [__] I mean oh darn it I've
never heard Tomic Shay swear in my
entire life and I've known him my entire
life oh my God and we've been together
every minute yeah it's been a weird life
we've had off two and a half years of it
oh God is that how long you've been
working at games spot two and a half
years yeah I celebrated my six six year
anniversary last
week it's a long time here it is a long
time here a lot of reviews that people
are mad
at oh
noell shock Shell Shocked dude what's
up man he's not looking so good I like
died when he was already holding his
butt in death when he sees us next time
he'll beat me but then he just
exploded you beat you beat Max in Mario
Kart and you told Max to [__] on his
head oh yeah that
happened that actually happened [__] on
your
head Mario Kart brings up brings out the
best
vulgarities what are these guys called
um I keep want to call them mousers but
there that's a different robot
yeah those are called I don't know look
at that beautiful sunset I think it's
actually like a bomb one off look at it
yeah it's actually Fallout it's actually
really bad yeah and we're still fighting
this is like the time that we should
love each other I guess we're fighting
for resources at this point yeah well
all the hyp stones really all the hyp
stones oh my God hyp Stones what's is
that a city yeah dude or was a city I
guess well it's it's dark whatever
there's a game called The Manhattan
Project they they welcome this
you you don't get much darker than the
Manhattan
Project I watched Dr Strange Love this
weekend for the first time in like 15
years is it hold
up uh that movie is amazing my favorite
quote from it is is an actually a quote
from the movie is what I found out but
my quote's better what the subtitle of
the movie no my favorite quote is uh
there's no fighting in the war room
that's not actually the quote but my
quote's way better
but that's that that I love
that I know that we're definitely
hitting our Audience by talking about a
movie that's like from 1962 yeah it's so
funny though it's
hilarious Peter cers is great they're
after our bodily
fluids what was his name what was his
name
uh who's Peter C's character's name he
played like eight characters man Drake
we have to protect Americans bodily
fluids from the communist regime
conspiracy
God here's character was all right but
he was a little too
like he he immediately became like okay
this guy's crazy I need to like talk to
him like he's a child and play his game
he he played like four
characters in that movie yeah Doctor
Strange Love he played four characters
in that movie I think he played Four he
played Just mandre he played Doctor
Strange
Love are you positive yes
you played a bunch of characters that's
what are you positive
yes I'll feel I'll feel kind of stupid
if that's true but I he totally
did we we'll look it up we'll look it up
on the
internet cuz I don't know if our
audience knows or
cares but yeah he he definitely played
Doctor Strange Love he was like that's
like if they if they ever remade that
movie it would have to have been someone
like Jim Carrey who can actually do tons
of different performances [__] I can't
do do this okay I'm going to do it we're
going to do it I'm going to do it I'm
going to do it talk about video games
talk about video games I don't know I
don't know what to what to say so Justin
hayal said Peter made it funny but that
doesn't actually
help um are you just I I can look it up
I have I have the internet here I got it
I got
it this is amazing yeah you're right he
did oh man that's so yeah that's crazy
he did a really good job then because I
did not realize how many characters play
uh all of them he played the woman we
are losing our streaming count bit by
bit so he played M
Drake you you [__] played the
president too you're just like shocked I
am shocked yeah cuz I really didn't get
Peter stellers was is like amazing how
did I not know that I don't know that's
incredible to me now's now we need to go
back and watch it again it's completely
different like that's that's why I say
it has to be Jim Carrey cuz Jim Carrey
can actually do completely different
performances recognize him but yeah like
that's just it though like I can
recognize Jim Cary he still has his like
Telltale yeah but it's only now that I
know that that was Sellers and I willing
to believe it care I
know cuz I definitely didn't tell his
Doctor Strange Love characters the most
ridiculous obviously
yeah I don't know I love they they never
even begin to explain why his right hand
is possessed no why would they that
movie is hysterical it's weird if you've
only seen like The Shining or you've
seen right yeah uh Clockwork Orange like
you would never think that kubri made a
hysterical movie right but it's one I
remember being one of the funniest
movies I but it's got his like Telltale
like Symmetry and what the hell does
that
mean what he frame is scene as symmetry
is that a thing yeah Tom frames a seam
of symmetry yeah yeah that means he's
got Jack Nichol down on the left and
right no but he would do things in The
Shining where like he would have um uh
what was the kid's name I don't know
Murder yeah the kid's name was murder
red
from he would have murder on the carpet
and the pattern would be you know like
lined up perfectly with the middle of
the frame and there's there's a few
shots like when they're checking out the
radar array um on the Air Force Base at
the beginning of uh Doctor Strange Love
but that's the thing and the kid's name
was murder I'm really liking why do we
name this kid murder don't ask
questions kuri knows he's doing oh man
so which one of these is going to come
alive or fall on us or something I don't
know you know one of them is going to
wasn't that weird that we oh God that's
what it was wasn't it weird that we
walked under those spikes at one point
they didn't fall on us I bet you they we
could have jumped into them though if we
weren't being careful God oh Shell
Shocked s going to make turtle sleep of
me oh and then last night I watched that
documentary on John milus that's on
Netflix who's John milus he's the
director behind like Conan the Barbarian
and Apocalypse Now or not he's not the
director he he wrote a lot of the
screenplays okay I was going be like not
now yeah I know yeah he was the director
of Conan I believe okay um but he yeah
he wrote a lot he wrote like screenplays
for some of the most iconic movies from
late' 70s to late late 80s then he got
in a really tragic I don't know if it
was an accident or like a a stroke I
forget but he totally lost his his
speech faculties so his memory is
perfect like you know like functionally
he's the same except he just can't speak
really well oh god um so he's been going
through therapy for a few years now but
he's actually still on board for um
third movie in the Conan series I didn't
know they're going to make a third one
yeah who's top two you know that
Japanese
guy we defeated all of your foot
soldiers man he's crapping
darts fles
chest I lose my myog
progress progress your kill score I did
it was more than yours I'll tell you
that much
well pu it I'm not throwing darts at you
hit you with wood you had if you had
darts all the
way we have like a super move or we hit
all the buttons together and it takes
out some of our hit A and B together yes
I'm not will I never even use C it's
like a run attack it's not even attack
he definitely does
it seems like you shouldn't do it you
don't have much
health I on the other
hand all right after this fight I'm
going to I'm going to use a Save State
why not I can do
that and you are so
softcore so softcore we have like
five we have we have a shitload of
continues yeah we're fine look at him I
don't want to lose I don't want to lose
my kill count though what we're not
going back you're not no
no no no all right uh let's beat that
boss we're going to take a quick
commercial break stay with us we will be
right
back hello you caught us what were we
doing nothing nothing all right back to
the game back to video games tom what do
you imagine that ad was for just now I
don't know we don't get to see the ad do
we uh is there such a thing is heat
sinks is from Michael Ba's new Teenage
meet Ninja Turtles film is that a thing
oh yeah you haven't seen the are you
kidding me I haven't seen anything I oh
man wait Michael ba Michael ba he's not
good at making movies how do I not know
this oh my God the turtles look awful
what do they look like do are they
humans they're so they all look slightly
different and they're like roided up and
like like weird and wide and the
proportions are strange and oh if I'm
trying to figure out if anything you
just said was racist was it racist no
okay man if our crew could throw on a
like an image of Michael Bay Turtles
right now I would be forever grateful
that's a are there is is there a trailer
out there I there might no there's not a
trailer out thing maybe there is but at
least I we only know what they look like
no we might there might be a trailer but
yeah I'm pretty are they production
Stills or like movie Stills no they're
like they're like stills of like here
what the turtles look like oh
God are we here already is this the
final level oh man this isn't Turtles in
Time by the way even if you say it is it
doesn't make it
true they share a bunch of levels
they're derived from are you sure yes
I'm positive Shell
Shocked get it cuz I have shells he
should say half shell
shocked but it's still a shell at that
point I mean half a shell is a shell is
it is there such a thing as half a
hole is there such a thing as half a
hole depends on what you're talking
about is this getting into a gross
territory cuz I don't want to do that no
anything you're making it gross so half
I don't cuz it's like it's a hole you
can't have half a hole it's just a hole
it's like half a shell right oh but you
brought it up and then now you're
basically defending my position whatever
oh god oh no oh no my two oh is that Max
kill count
255 I killed him too like right away
that's how it
works people arguing about half a hole
somebody said that he Cliffy Cliffy T
says he likes the way the the turtles
look yeah he might just be talking about
this the Micha B I'm going to assume
he's talking about this game cuz based
on what you said so who is uh is what's
just name in the movie what's his name
huh the hell is his name the dude who
was in the the Transformers
movies what you mean shy abff shy abff
in the in that movie yeah he's he's
Michael Ba's like you know favorite
actor to use so yeah so he's in that
yeah he is all the turtles actually he
does all the motion capture and Voice
work for every Turtle I'm going to
assume you're not is he not in the movie
I don't think he's in the movie is Megan
Fox shff has like taken like a Hiatus
from acting after doing that like stage
plagiarism yeah he could doesn't mean he
could be in a
movie I'm on still working is Megan Fox
in it is she April O'Neal she actually
plays um Optimus Prime in the Turtles
movie oh that sounds cool by the way I
haven't seen a a Transformer movie since
the first Transformer movie uh yeah but
the new one has Dinobots in it Dark of
the Moon or something no that was that
was another one which is like a the
weirdest subtitle ever not even Dark
Side of
Moon Megan Fox is April O'Neal wow I was
totally right about that wow it's only
cuz I couldn't remember Rosie
Huntington's name is that who to
replaced oh God we just killed this
bastard yo Max do you want to go to my
desk and get turtles in time so we can
put that in if we're about to beat the
game it's in uh my right set of drawers
on the bottom there are two boxes of
cartridges uh look through there it
might have Genesis carts on top
thanks I can't believe I was right about
April O'Neal oh yeah I can cuz he does
always has the same actors wasn't John
Lego in the first
Transformers was he is that a thing did
I make that up I don't know I just like
thinking about John lamo that guy's
pretty funny he's
great yeah so we were watching my wife
and I are watching the uh basetball
yesterday and then there a commercial
came up for uh I don't know American
Express or something something dumb
right and it was Kevin spy and she was
like I can't believe he's doing
commercials Jackson is doing commercials
uh well I can't I have Capital One
credit card I have something to say
about that also but I'm going to
continue with the Spacey story so she's
like I can't believe he's doing
commercials cuz she like she likes him
she respects him oh so did you tell him
about the game tell her about the game I
told her that he's in Call of Duty and
she goes no is he doing it as like a
protest against Call of Duty and I was
like no I think he's doing it as like a
I like money in any form yeah and I have
this new found Fame and I will use it to
my advantage yeah cuz he he has resur he
had Fame before but this is like a
different Fame in like 94 through like
99 and then it went away with K packs
and now it's back because of House of
Cards and he's just like he'll he just
says yes to everything
apparently Subway commercial yes all
right Stockman is that
bter back Stockman was the fly or
something like
that I that's another movie I haven't
seen in Gold Jeff gold I know Jeff also
Peter sers as Jeff Goldblum so do you
want to know what I had to say about the
Sam the Samuel Jackson Capital One
commercial yeah okay sure so I don't
know if you've ever heard Magic Johnson
speak or tweet or
anything have you yes but he says
exclusively things that are not awesome
basically you've said this I heard you
say this yesterday I say this way too
often cuz every time I thought I have
I'm continually reminded of it so like
he had a tweet saying like shout out to
my to my friend samel Jackson who's in
these commercials that are perfect for
his ability and I'm like are you kidding
a Capital One commercial is the perfect
thing for have you seen fault fault
fiction so I don't know that's that's
just every time I see it I just think
about Magic Johnson just being Magic
Johnson just saying Magic Johnson things
saying the most magical things I know oh
Stockman I hate you he's easy what does
he even no I know but I just don't like
him he's easy
though like like easy yeah he's like a
Sunday morning there's another reference
that are gross that our all of our
viewers totally
get fath the more covered that song easy
like a Sunday morning that's how I know
it oh you found it what I find oh he did
find it Turtles and time is this the one
that's made out of
chocolate what even are you talking
about all right so we're going to put
this in if we beat this game right now
what time is it we've got like four
continues oh we got like 20 minutes we
got like 20 minutes
yeah was a
kickass he his throat cut and kick I
haven't seen kickass to he just spoiled
the whole movie for me I might have did
you see kickass hey dudes let's go uh
yeah kickass is great this a good one I
don't know that I'd watch it again I
don't one what I do did you watch the
sequel no I did not I did not but I love
the first one cuz it had Nikki cage in
it
I'm not a huge Nick Cage fan even though
it's like you know like he's an ironic
person to like I was a fan of his way
before it was cool I'm just going to
throw that out there no longer hate him
but just laugh well there's like so much
like ironic love toward like I cuz I
always cuz I okay
so 99 2000 2000 my my like girlfriend at
the time had to do a movie project and
she chose Nikki cage and we watched all
his movies to that point yeah including
Cotton Club which was his first movie
and I that's when I fell in love with
him because he's super cool I also think
it's great that he's uh cuz he's a
legitimate actor right uh the answer is
yes he won an Academy Award like he's a
real actor I mean he's a real person who
play who is an actor like as a job he
has real acting Talent he has an Academy
Award you can't argue with this I can't
argue that he has an Academy Award but I
could argue about his acting Talent so
it's rare to find with real acting
Talent who's willing to do like Bizarro
weird awesome type roles as opposed to
just like about this it is cuz usually
you get someone like Leo who I love Leo
but he does the same kind of like I'm
kind of a jerk Rich dude like that's
kind of his role he has sort of fallen
into that role at the moment he but his
past was very different yeah he did
Gilbert Grape I remember that a million
years ago but it's it's just rare that
like cuz Nikki c will do anything I
imagine he totally gets into every role
and I love that you got to imagine leard
DiCaprio has is going to have like some
weird like Reawakening where he just
does like the bizarre he better he
better do something else as much as I
love Gatsby and I'm the one person you
know it's a little obvious that he was
going to play
Gatsby now if you would have played
Daisy it would have been interesting
like Daisy from Mario Kart I'm Daisy now
I still don't know who Daisy is is she
anything other than like an
athlete is she like Luigi's she just
like a real princess something or what
does she do what is her thing she's just
like really nice and helpful what is her
place in the Mushroom
Kingdom uh good citizen
seriously does that imply everyone else
is a bad citizen no darn it there could
be more than one good citizen H go
on I think guys made my point okay you
don't know what she is
either Wonder did you see look it's a
Foot Locker
see oh Tom the thing it's that was the
game that was
Konami their tree house fny you know now
that I think about it it's weird that
there was never like a Foot Locker like
series of sports games back in the
day does that does that sound that
strange to you like the T like the the
there were so many games for these old
systems that were just coming like in so
many sports games that like weren't they
didn't have official licenses like
techmobile they didn't have the [__]
nflp license are you talking about Foot
Locker the shoe store yeah I'm talking
about Foot Locker shoe store why would
there be a Foot Locker game oh no I'm
not talking about a game where you like
manage a Foot Locker oh that would be
awesome like a branded Foot Locker game
at least one I bet I think I bet you I
bet you that it came up at some point I
bet the best thing when you work at Foot
Locker is when you convince someone to
buy a shoe that's like totally not their
size cuz that's got to feel pretty good
right I'm not sure why that would feel
good well cuz you're very persuasive
salesperson what do you mean so just
that the fact that you're able to sell
someone on something that they shouldn't
even want yeah that's it's got to feel
good
right I don't know manipulating people
yeah no that's really that's really what
I'm talking about like if someone's in
like obvious physical pain and you can
still be like no drop 150 on the shoe
like that's that's pretty
cool it's pretty that's admirable it's
like a real good day at work that's
admirable that's like the the Nobel
Prize for like being a jerk mind control
basically look at there skeletons in the
background I never know how to avoid
these
balls I know how to get hit by them yeah
I'm really good at that I'm really good
at getting hit by them and I I have way
more kills than
you
five all right that's what this game has
become now it's about the number of
kills I have versus the number of kills
Tom has now yeah it wasn't like that
before but you keep bringing it up so
it's always been
that have you used AB yet
yeah they're so stupid with their little
Speedos like like they even have Rock
junk down there well they better have
Rock junk how else do they reproduce do
they reproduce I just thought they were
Monsters made in a laboratory I just
assume all monsters
reproduce where do monsters come from if
not from
junk oh doctors mad scientists yeah but
even well the turtles don't reproduce
they don't have any pants so they don't
have anything to cover up Turtles don't
wear pants in real life but they still
have
junk
pants does not equate junk damn it
you're really bad shut up can we also
keep track of how how often you get oh
my god oh
no I'll show you the power of super
crang give mean sexy
cray I think we we moved after we were
my God that is the worst kick that is a
real jerk kick
yeah we should really focus on cray and
not the not the body I guess the body
would probably still fight us even if
cran was dead wouldn't it I don't think
so cuz he controls it yeah with his mind
oh God he's shooting stuff out of his
mouth I love how old bosses back in the
day used to just be able to go off
screen and I was like yeah we can't we
can't go over there oh no
oh whatever dude I know you can't hit
him when he's doing that it's like real
life
dude I feel like there's more to come
yeah the Super
Shredder right there's got to be
Shredder see Super Shredder that kill
count Tom I don't know what it is I
didn't see it oh look at that that's
awkward I'm going to disadvantage CU
well actually Michelangelo is pretty
good in this game it's just Raphael
who's not as
good he got his little baby
weapon why don't you tell everyone home
what you think those are called size
okay what do you think they're called no
that's what they're called it started
sound like you were starting to say it
and then perverted to Baby
weapon I thought going to correct my
pronunciation I did that when you say
ikaruga but karuga isn't it karuga
karuga karuga it's a
karuga
kuga yeah I got that I got that guys no
problem what do you want me to pronounce
cuz I will pronounce it however I damn
well
pleased look how impatient you are with
your dumb
foot you're like the song of the
Hedgehog of
turtles like I am blue yeah I know yeah
don't remind me
I I'd be blue too if people compared me
to song of the Hedgehog see what I did
there I said blue is a sad
joke look at how I kick like that like
how do you do that weird kick that one
how do you do that
kick that is a weird looking kick mine
no this not not that not the diving one
but the other one sideways one yeah I've
been trying to figure that one that one
I just did I'm looking at me man it's
all about me that one oh so that one you
do you press attack like pretty soon
jumping yeah go look how dumb it is that
doesn't do any
damage look at how dumb it is it's great
I love
it do you think there's a point when
they were like learning how to be ninjas
where like both Michelangelo and
Leonardo both wanded like a sword and
then and then Splinter or Shredder was
like not only one of you can have a
sword well the other one's got to take
these these like wooden things
Donatella like calculated the advantage
of having such range and leverage well I
mean you know yeah I know do you think
that this act cuz what are the odds that
they all chose different weapons maybe
it was that thing where
like like there was some sort of like
test not like a test like a scenario
where like fate would decide what weapon
they they were
given fate yeah who's that I don't know
her
I'm hoping people answer in the comments
like no there was there was this
scenario this is why he took us they
chose straws that was it also three eyes
what is
that a real Super Shredder it is look at
him
flying now I will show you the real
power of the
hyperstone what is what is he doing
shooting crap in the air like that God
he's instantly pain in the butt isn't he
this guy might have been designed to
take my quarters I'm going to throw that
out
there Shell Shocked oh God this guy was
definitely designed to take quarters
[__] what is that sound that that
sound it's a man screaming in pain it
doesn't really sound like I'm hitting
him it sounds like a clown in a box
being like thrown around oh my God he
got turned into a mutant little baby
turtle it's the power of the hyperstone
dude underestimate it let's the opposite
of a
hyperstone
uh
a like a a disappointing Rock a
disappointing Rock a uh a mediocre Rock
hyper doesn't mean I know I know but but
what is what is the Anin but well it
would be something like a like slow yeah
it would be something like like slow
wouldn't it but that's not here doesn't
it doesn't imply in this in this
scenario it doesn't imply speed or
anything it implies like it's a real
Mega thing the real Mega thing yeah what
does that mean it's like a it's it's
like a stone but like the hyper version
of a stone you got to know what I'm
talking about here I know you know this
is the worst conversation I've
had hey progress progress progress you
getting your butt kick with
score too about having killed a single
enemy this entire game you've also been
Leonardo for the entire game which is
awkward nobody got to see Raphael at all
well this is a dumb
fight it' be better if there's some kind
of a rap going
on a turtle rap yeah or ninja WAP go are
they going to have that song in the new
Michael Bay
movie it' be weird if they didn't right
go ninja go
I have a feeling there's going to be
like almost no references to Classic
Ninja Turtles why are they making a new
Ninja turt a trailer now that I think
about it I think there is a trailer I
don't know cuz the cartoon's popular is
it yeah
huh wait wait wait don't die off screen
it's like
Cyclops X-men 3 you died off screen yeah
it's amazing here go here we
go what's going to happen
wait there more than one
hyperstone uh
oh Meg Fox here I've been in front of
the Statue of Liberty for the entire
time we'll say 45
minutes Capital City
yeah normal size who is really
responsible for saving this
city
what no we did it Pete and Tom you are
the worst
reporter that guy was amazing that was
coima wasn't
it he look the
kamami oh
man they're in a blimp I guess I don't
know why it's this extreme closeup I
love when they would go in the streets
with like a trench coat it's like yeah I
see that you have green gross feet
dude
Whoa man all right I'm going to pop this
game out and we're going to put in
Turtles and time for the last 10 minutes
or so of this stream I know according to
Tim Finnegan there is a
trailer okay so we have to watch this
trailer kimaru says I saw the trailer
and it sucked and I wonder if there is a
splinter even in the movie I wonder if
there is a splinter spinter is there no
one noticed him
Cliffy there has to be a splinter let
see
see dark beat says classic April is
better than teen April there's there's
multiple
aprils I don't even know April I don't
know is she still a reporter is she
still is she like in high school I don't
know she's like literally like
14 yeah cool there we go all
right how old is April O'Neal
normally good question and one I'm not
prepared to answer there you go how old
are the turtles
they're teenagers so 13 19 17 I think
what happens when they're not a turtle
teenagers anymore uh they get put out to
pasture I have the wrong controller
versus we'll do first versus we've got
eight minutes and we could we don't have
to stop at
11 going to be Raphael the same
character select
screen
h
all right so the controls are different
cuz oh you don't have enough buttons I
wonder who's going to win this fight so
we're playing this game right now a
Super Nintendo game with Genesis
controllers which is convenient but if
you only have a three button controller
like Tom you don't get to attack unless
you
remap come
here I'm definitely going for the draw
37 seconds left damn it Tom no
no come back this is so boring no no I I
have no way to attack I can only jump
and
complain why are they fighting each
other it's called practice no it's not
they're hitting each other with their
sticks I'm going to win dude you might
win but I'm not going to get killed damn
it I think what you should what you
should be shouting is I'm going to put
you in a bathtub since that's what
happened in the first Turtles
movie all right let's play
legit n this is best out of a million
sorry I totally forgot that they had
that mode options do you want to see if
they have the anime or comic
option same screen except it got Raph up
top now leard up
before where's how do I play let me do
the how do I play with the controls you
want to remap the buttons we'd have to
exit the game time we don't have enough
time so you're just going to have to
follow me okay we'll do it and not die
we'll do it we'll do it there's going to
be a lot of me complaining just so you
know just accept your fate I'm going to
be Raphael cuz whatever if I have more
kills than you then you got to you got
to seriously look look within okay so
that was that was going to be the same
intro roughly back this is back not the
same but roughly way different
levels moving way faster also look at
the graphics look way different yeah cuz
they look better on the Genesis although
we chose the comic ones so maybe that's
why before it was the
animation so maybe the comic yeah cuz in
the comics they didn't really have
pupils as much as they had just like
sorry I did that they had just uh these
white things plus they all they all only
had red bandanas so they really going to
be true to the comics they would have
stuck with that
whatever you doing it Tom I'm living
you're not
Live and Not
Die 's motto I got totally kicked like a
like a
jerk this is the stage that back to
Stockman he was he was a He's a fly he's
totally a
fly I don't think that this wrecking
ball is being used
properly
and I thought that I saw that jump kick
and I thought it was me and I got really
excited but I don't get I don't get what
are these other buttons even
doing I'm sorry we stumbled into this
and you can't play but it's kind of fun
watching you struggle too yeah it is
it's not fun for you but no it's it's
kind of fun it's kind of fun what do you
think is in this Danger Room kills you
have though I have zeros oh that's right
I have zero kills this game is making me
weirdly hungry or pizza where do you
think I can get turtle soup in the
city uh probably a number of restaurants
maybe uh what's it called McDonalds they
have a good uh value menu turtle soup
nice brisk bis bis nice nice thick brisk
sou I had a I ate a whole crab the other
night and it's weird to eat a whole crab
yeah unless it's deep fried you probably
shouldn't eat the
shell I didn't need the shell I cracked
it open I'm sorry are you are we back to
this whole half of a whole conversation
St
again it was a whole crab on my plate
but I only ate the meat part of it and I
actually asked the the waiter I was like
is there any poop in this and he goes no
I actually asked him that he literally
said is there any poop in my I didn't
say it like that but I did say I said is
there I I don't know I said is there
pooping this cuz like are you serving me
[__] well cuz Bridget had eaten uh
that's my wife she had eaten uh a whole
crab once in her life when she was in
Boston and she said at one point she was
eating the poop and someone's like
you're not supposed to eat that yeah
well there's there yeah there's like
there are parts of it that you're not
supposed to eat but that but they gave
us thinging that we were supposed to eat
everything apparently gotta cuz they de
pooped it or whatever you're supposed to
do and when you got shrimp it's called
Dev Vining although I don't know the
exact term it is just
poop it's kind of weird e a whole crab
maybe I'll do it again in 10 years it's
kind of
weird it's kind of weird soft shell
crab's really good never Vis my parents
in Carolina hey there it goes into the
sced mode seven y mode seven which is a
real thing it
is toly real
thing kenami did some really cool stuff
uh like with Castlevania Bloodlines did
some really interesting things that I'm
not sure would have been possible on the
Super Nintendo although maybe they could
have been but [__] come on I got to
focus here cuz I'm not helping somebody
mentioned a
desks he said there's R not fighting I'm
not fighting because I have to remap the
controls which I have to do like outside
of the game we're playing a Super
Nintendo game on a Genesis controller
but I have six buttons and Tom only has
three yeah which yeah if you missed it
we were playing hyperstone Heist before
and I'm kind of putting in turtles in
times to people an idea we took us 50
minutes to beat hyperstone Heist we want
we had some time to
kill I'm
right oh man what is that it's gross
I'll tell you oh dude come on
Jeff Jeff Goblin is is backer Stockman
in the new turtles and he's played by
Jeff gold oh that'd be pretty awesome
because that would be pretty awesome I
don't know if Michael Bay is that like
inspired with his choices though you see
Michael Ba's speech at CES in January I
know I heard that he pouted like a baby
he got on for like Samsung to do
something and his teleprompter went out
and he like tried to wing it and he
lasted about 5 seconds and then he just
walked off he said I'm sorry and he
walked off the stage in the middle of
this like giant presentation where he
was like the key guy he's a real baby
isn't he I mean in his defense he wrote
a blog post that was like yeah that was
really unprofessional but I kind of like
lost my cool I didn't know what to do
like no one else's fault but my own 16
kills all right we're going to wrap it
up at this point uh thanks for joining
us everybody that was really fun yeah
teen Monday fun I know oh no terrible
terrible um yeah did you have fun I well
yeah that was really good yeah it was a
great time cool what are you playing on
next week that's a good question I don't
know yet uh if you guys have any
suggestions for what we should play next
week uh tweet me at PC Brown on Twitter
uh or use the hashtag megabit I'll keep
eyes on that okay and uh I've got a
pretty extensive Library so maybe I'll
have something you guys want to see um
but yeah thanks for watching enjoy the
rest of your day come back at 2 pm to
watch Chris Waters and Mary Kish what
are they play to jam and Earl Panic on
funkatron yeah yeah you love that game
though I love tojam and RL not planet on
funkatron as much but no it's a cool
it's a really cool game and they both
love it yeah so that should be fun yeah
and Chris is playing it for video game
history month which is still ongoing a
gam spot May is just I don't know we're
only 12 days in we got another half
month to go so yeah uh go to video
gamespot.com vghm to check out all that
great content and uh yeah thanks for
watching everyone see you next
Monday
oh